API keys, database passwords, TLS certs.
Don't put them in your image, use a secret.
A secret is like a config map, but for sensitive data.
Created independently of paths.
Injected at runtime, not baked into the image.
Here's the catch.
Secrets are not encrypted by default.
They're base 64 encoded.
That's encoding, not encryption.
Anyone with ECT access can read them.
To make secrets actually secret, enable encryption at rest
and lock down RBAC.
Three ways to use a secret.
One, inject as environment variables.
Two, mount as files in a volume.
Three, image pull secret for private container registries.
Use secrets, encrypt ed, restrict RBAC.
Or use an external vault.
Don't commit credentials to your image.
Run the docs, Kubernetes secrets.